[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just to bring your wonderful personality
it's friday it's fun friday here at the
break room we're in the new rockstar's
actual break room here at our wonderful
headquarters and uh we're excited to
bring this show to you
we this is a high concept show today
that i'm going to explain to you great
you have two guests here today
we've got two uh people sitting in on
the panel so we're gonna spring on them
some elaborate concepts and rules uh but
we're thrilled to have you here with us
live we're totally live right now today
we're talking stranger things uh we're
battling the vechna we're talking craven
the hunter taika what td star wars
movies kenobi so much on the news
break room
oh we have a jingle
rock stars break room
break room
don't make it we're talking we're
talking star wars
people love the intro music thank you
john for putting that together of course
let me introduce everybody here i'll
start well i i'm joined as i often am by
the wonderful jessica clemens
inner wizard gown that is for a reason
we'll explain shortly
it's a wonderful thematic outfit from
what you normally want
she was wearing it anyways and we were
like we better have a fun thing to do
but we have a special guest here mr
phillip molina i lied when i said i
wasn't going to be here tomorrow yeah
yes
under promise over deliver that's
phillips motto and then uh for just this
second or third time on screen that's
right as a person i'm here you get a
chair now i cut you off yeah you often
you often just kind of pop in maybe they
just get a side profile but we get uh
producer john
in the chair thank you john thank you
for having me i'm excited i heard we
were rolling dice today and i needed to
insert myself into this this is the
producer of this show makes this the uh
the live element here and in person here
running around plugging wires in and i
don't know what else you do you just you
waste the rest of it my best friend and
best producer oh
both of those are true uh but uh you can
also you just demanded yourself to be on
the show that's right yes just so it's
clear that's right well hey i mean it's
appropriate tom cruise the producer of
top gun maverick for comparing me to tom
cruise i'm also a scientologist
never end this is also a news show where
we cover news
yes this is uh the reason we do this
show is to cover the news of the day the
nerdy news that you want to hear about
all the kind of great stuff we cover at
new rock stars we get to do it live and
in more depth here and because this is a
fun friday we and we have like a little
bit of an extra concept today we we do a
chat redemption here on the show where
anytime we hit a multiple of 100 bucks
in super chats due to your generosity it
it spurs something into action it causes
something to happen on the show and
today in honor of the release of season
four of stranger things anytime we hit a
redemption we are going to battle the
vechna
in the style of tabletop gaming okay
dungeon master not trademarked tabletop
that's right
uh um uh
table tabletop dungeon master jessica
will be leading us um we have some
of the dice oh we've got a 20-sided and
uh and a d12 and a d12 over there um
some elaborate eminem uh video packages
involved with this
it's gonna be really cool guests special
guests perhaps yes special er
than john
yes the most special and and again we
are without tommy bechdel today who's
down in anaheim for star wars
celebration where him and eric are kind
of watching all the panels and reporting
back on all the big star wars news
you've probably seen that eric did not
know that tommy would be there and uh is
now very uh uh uh
struggling very much yeah i believe
there was a hotel mix-up and it's sort
of like a plane's trains automobiles
yeah
in a hotel
john candy and eric yeah i got videos
those will not
if you're in uh orange county and you
see eric voss driving around like an 88
oldsmobile with the doors ripped off and
the roof ripped off you know that is
tommy bechtold's fault but first because
this is a new show as philip riley
pointed out let's do some headlines
talking about headlines
there it is hell yeah
thank you thank you daschle uh um we've
got our first look at the logo for
craven the hunter do we do we have an
answer for this i think maybe
oh there it is oh that's nice
oh i think so this was on a crew wrap
gift it was like a backpack we sort of
punched in here um but it's got like
those little fangs going on yeah it's
got it it's got an arrow or maybe a
spear or something like wait can you put
it up again you said the fangs where's
the thing
it's kind of on the edges
i think uh okay
the arrows is very prominent i wanted it
to be a little more animalistic but
it's given something yeah we don't know
um i also love like the shooting in at
least
one
team of filming is going on in the uk
okay yeah yeah probably multiple
locations for a film of this size and
scope but i think that that was a wrap
gift so it sounds like they finished
done uh isn't it also giving morbius it
is giving morbius which makes sense it's
the same same people same studio okay
go bring that up um
i'm still very excited about this movie
i think craven is such a cool character
i'm i think aaron taylor johnson will do
a really good job he looks great in some
of those sort of like behind the scenes
photos that have come out um
but you know
do we have to like manage our
expectations for this i think you can
dream big okay yeah i'm still allowed to
be excited
not at all about craving the hunter but
the more we keep making memes of morbius
you guys the more reason they're going
to make another more beautiful and it's
going to reference all the memes i will
see
um
speaking of uh anaheim and star wars
celebration we got more news lucasfilm
confirmed that the next star wars
theatrical release is going to be this
taika waititi directed movie that
they're saying 2023 as far as we know
this movie has not started filming yet
these movies take a long time to film
and to finish and special effects but
that's what they're saying yeah you know
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier star wars loves they're like
december christmas releases for their
movies lately the weird thing is like
all those avatar sequels are coming out
around the same time
um you know oh uh do we know anything
about the movie
the taika movie mm-hmm i think the thing
maybe we know is that it's like not
connected yeah interesting a new story
yeah uh you think it'll be
more like jojo rabbit or more like thor
ragnarok oh probably ragnarok that's the
one that makes the big bucks right
that's probably what they're signing up
for star wars movies to be like ragnarok
yeah
silly character i don't think that's
going to be as silly i think it's going
to be like when he did the episode of um
mandalorian i was a book of boba the
mandalorian i think it'll be i think he
can't i think there's like
uh i get a box of what they will let
them go outside of for star wars and
taekwondo they're like ah pull back i
think he's got to do empire characters
the way that he did nazis and jojo
rabbit
you know what i mean like a little bit
bungalow i didn't mind that we got a
little bit of a taste of like what an
empire sympathetic character would be
with finn and i don't i don't think we
like exploring that as well as we could
have so that'd be a lot of fun i have a
question for you guys what would be like
what is taika waititi's like cgi
character or his you know his like
yeah what is his you know like korg or
what i think it's another droid he's
gonna play another droid
droid is easy yeah
yeah maybe even i want like simon pegg
in that force awakens where you you know
the uh
his character with the with the credits
and
he was like
he was like this is
not enough credit yeah
that's what i want oh well and taika
enjoys putting himself in his films and
via voice or in person maybe maybe you
would get a live-action tyke in this
film i'll take a live-action type
yes
yeah the guy has a pretty strong track
record folks watching our flag means
death out there right now i'm enjoying
the hell out of that show it's a great
hitler
okay
all right the number of times you say
that about different people
okay uh we got a uh a really cool i mean
this show's already out we're gonna be
talking more about obi-wan throughout
the episode today because those first
two episodes just dropped but we got a
a really cool looking poster
i think we have that asset they just put
out a new ooh
like little tease of this showdown that
they've been sort of hyping up for so
long you know this is like a little
modified version of this was on the
disney plus splash page when you clicked
into the episodes last night i was with
a few friends and my star wars like die
hard friend almost fell off the couch he
was so excited
and it's it's framed in a very old west
kind of way like you're looking through
the arm of the gunfighter kind of i hope
they i hope they're battling in the
desert that would be so fun if by like
the end they're just like straight up
the best scene is darth maul and him
fighting in the desert and i want to see
him well animated i want to see him
fight
no i'm feeling it i want to see him
fight darth vader also in the sand in
the desert set to duel of the fates
it's finally the payoff
whose fates right right oh interesting
well and we also know right
if they fight in this series hey they
might fight multiple times in the series
but it's the middle of three
right like uh
the you know because we know how it
eventually ends for kenobi in a new hope
right and that's that's a really good
point because you know anakin certainly
had the the short end of the stick in
the first fight kenobi obviously in this
in the in the fight that we've seen in
the new hope you think maybe in this
fight they just both go back licking
their wounds and well it's tough i mean
when we know neither character can die
in the fight that kind of re removes
some stakes now here's what i'm gonna
pitch maybe it's a three-way fight
ooh and we don't know what's going to
happen to that third character
you know what i mean a little menage a
saber
i don't know three swords three swords
oh three swords i love it yeah i'm here
for you i don't know is it the ghost of
qui-gon
if it's oh we need to talk about it it
literally could not be a duel
a duel with three people is a troll
that's not a joke that's actually that's
canada that's canon hashtag troll uh
who's the third person
well i mean you have an idea i mean
third sister she's already got the
number that works maybe i think he's
gone it's a qui-gon force ghost similar
to
luke in
uh last shout out so
a little bit recreating the mall fight
from phantom menace
he's trying to he's trying to reach out
i think quite wow okay john john costa's
taking big swings already uh let's let's
jump right into more kenobi talk we all
watched the first two episodes last
night start uh uh hi to the chat by the
way
chat yet um thank you uh so much uh
andrew mc manama yeah uh you're uh
manimal uh and i love you uh uh thank
you for your great content on ours the
fairest of all the youtube nerd channels
there's so much manufactured negativity
from some of the others it is truly
manufactured by the way it's like if
they just pretend to hate everybody hold
on let me get angry about this for once
no
manufacturer john uh by the way in the
chat in general you can be posting
kenobi questions yes please we've all
seen it but yes please please please and
in fact maybe we'll throw a poll up
there about last night's two kenobi
episodes maybe how many people finished
immediately how many people are are
waiting to watch that it would be weird
if you hadn't seen it and you're
watching the show but i don't know what
people's schedules are like kind of late
in there in the evening yes also real
quick shout out to quentin b asking
about butt blue beetle i don't know if
you guys saw that our boy sholo
maridonia uh
they have a picture now that that came
out i don't know if it was officially
released of him in costume
looks great that helmet looks big
with the big head game it might be
remember yesterday we were talking about
you need big fish head broom
i think it was this that i was seeing
was reminding me of like some of those
aquaman costumes where i was like oh
yeah that is a big that's a big head
gang right there all right but that's a
quick shout out for thank you
okay um so
we all watched those first two episodes
last night right kind of like i think
most people probably consumed them as a
whole it was about you know if you
skipped the credits it was about an hour
of content total a little bit over um
uh big thoughts i mean baby leia you
nailed that i did nailed it no i didn't
know i was getting tweets about you it's
one of those things in hindsight they
show us baby luke in the trailer yeah do
you think that's the last time we see
baby luke in this series no absolutely
not oh
interesting because because it'd be like
it was a misdirection yes no they're
gonna come full circle i think once
leia's brought back to her family then
he's going to be like i did all of this
i overcame everything now i i don't care
what uncle what says i'm going in there
and i'm going to talk to that child you
think that there's going to be a moment
where maybe baby leia ends up on
tatooine and is so close to baby i
and not that not that this is predictive
necessarily but that show poster we just
looked at appears to be on a desert
planet now there are other desert
planets besides tatooine but we know
they love to go to tattoos they do enjoy
a tattoo shoot in uh
outside of vegas like 30 miles on time
yeah yeah
uh i'll say of course baby leia made a
lot of sense uh after you you said it
and then after we saw it when it was
like help me uh obi-wan kenobi you're my
only hope we've never really known much
about in any of the live-action content
how does she have such strong feelings
about this guy being her only hope and
it's like yeah of course the kenobi
series because he's come through in the
past right yeah yeah yeah i really like
that the sorry i'm taking this back but
as soon as that episode opened on order
66 i screamed from my office and i was
like order 66 and everyone was like are
you okay i was like how are you going to
open with the saddest moment
the craziest moment i thought we were
going to get anakin
i know i was like are they really going
to show up they were going to run into
anakin was going to slice those kids you
guys know that eric vostok uh that he
always had about that scene and uh the
order 66 scene where anakin does go
math anakin
baby bad ones or whatever
it's such a stupid joke but it always
makes me laugh where you know he lights
up his lightsaber and it just shows like
the kid likes staring and then just eric
just always it says that they cut out
the part where the kid goes
which is such a stupid thing for them to
have had
eric like brings that up every year
the curdling death scream of a small
child i feel like it's super obvious
that of course some people got away from
order 66 i just didn't think about it
and as soon as those kids ran away i was
like oh oh yeah i bet a lot of well
and the way things were cut right we
were led to believe that maybe some of
those kids that got away
either become the uh rogue jedis that
are out there flewing like uh fleeing
like benny saftey in this first episode
right or become the inquisitors
speaking of which
uh i love gr grand inquisitor i know i
know this is obviously going to be a
little bit more of third sister story
but like the look the voice of grand
inquisitor rupert friend is doing some
work different yeah yeah he does i knew
him from uh uh what's the carry uh
uh the show about the cia
uh that one show
homeland yeah yeah he's got a major role
in homeland he's like the badass on that
show but he's kind of like gritty and
and i think not british on that and not
british um this he's he's he's really
and brandon inquisitor as soon as he
showed up i was like oh i'm cosplaying
oh yeah i'm putting he looks great he
looks huge he like towers over everybody
he's like isn't he a little too big
right here he's got like headphones he's
got like heaven
those beats are too big
that's a question that i've been
wondering i've seen it a lot online it's
like okay
this is a spoiler show we know that yes
yes spoilers for obi-wan if you're not
watching
and you don't know the spoilers they're
spoilers um
he gets killed at the end of the episode
right but we know he's in rebels
what is the deal there does he not get
killed are we going to see him again
uh was it a retcon yeah jessica's been
saying
he's definitely not he's definitely not
dead we also didn't get to see him like
gasp or anything it was such a quick
scene he's just bent over sorry there it
is
is that just here this whole time yeah
yeah
i've been slowly twisting it forever
yeah i've noticed thank you
um but yeah i don't think he's dead i
think the chat can agree i don't think
the grand inquisitor is dead oh that'd
be a good chat have any other options
first off we want
i mean i want to repeat uh that star
wars which the current poll which star
wars disney plus show had the best first
episode 52 saying kenobi now that might
be recency bias oh it's totally wrong
it's because that intro dude that intro
it was it was a really nice thing that
has a great band yeah
that whole pilot like a flashback and
also i'm talking about like the very
first like here's the flashback here's
what you missed the recap the recap was
very well done
right into order 66 that was pretty cool
but the whole first episode
yes
and i think i think the love for
mandalorian kind of shining there
through um uh
we were what were we we were just oh
another chat let's let's throw up in the
poll uh a new poll is grand inquisitor
alive or dead yeah what are we doing
do we think we see him live more on
screen in obi-wan wha while they
chat does that can we talk a little bit
more about baby leia i'm just like this
is what she what she's like also okay um
i'm not the i'm not the star wars queen
not star wars queen i'm a dog that's
christina ariel look her up she's
actually doing oh yeah that's my baby
girl she's we get our hair done in the
same place either way either way i'm not
her
so who's leia's family leia's family
she's talking to so we have the cousin
and then we have the other siblings who
are the other people that were there
like who are the extended organic clan
yeah so am i i'm asking do we know i
don't i don't know
well we've met bale before obviously
jimmy smits everybody else in the room
yes we don't know well there are people
of different species those might be
friends and friends and family
yeah
space farm environments okay i just
wanted to make sure i was like i don't
know who these people are but i didn't
know if i was
but i will say i hope that kid dies
first the cousin
i was also like i don't care if baby
leia is supposed to be 10 and looks like
she's like four
i'm like she's that actress the
enunciation she was giving with that
monologue of like you suck yeah and i'm
the better one and i can't wait to take
you and then when she clapped on every
word
get them i said eat them
beat him up yeah she was great she had
great line delivery for an actress that
young great lines they made her really
smart but then it just frustrated me
when then uh in the other episode she
was like oh i can't catch her and she's
like you're never gonna get me yeah the
most the most nimble uh again
six-year-old uh
cosplaying as a ten-year-old i don't
know very strange choice to make them
10. i get that they have to do a time
jump because it's been 10 years since
order 66 and the end of uh right um the
final prequel film but
that kid does not look anywhere near 10.
i don't i don't think luke necessarily
looked i mean we got a very small
glimpse of him as he was like whipping
on the top of it but also obi-wan has
has definitely aged more than 10 years
right because it has been
it has been like 23 right yeah yeah yeah
yeah but also he has to get to alec
guinness aged in the next 13 years right
now i think right right right
poll came in do you think the grand
inquisitor is dead 85 percent said no
yeah and i think i agree with that um
and i do think we're gonna see more of
him in this series but interestingly
enough you know at new rockstars we're
all trailer hounds here and we like comb
through every shot um
i i don't we most of the shots from the
trailer i feel like we're in this first
couple of episodes that's right well but
there could be a variety of reasons for
that there were no um
no baby leia shots obviously in the
trailer they were kind of holding that
back and yeah almost all of the fighting
scenes and like the different locations
we've already kind of seen though yeah
it was two oh no i was going to comment
on the fighting scenes uh two things
okay i'm glad
two things first off we
skimmed over the fact that uh obi-wan
threw spice on the ground like a witch
and a huge
technically free spice it was free okay
this is the part where i'm irritated how
important is that basically how
important is spice because in um book of
boba fett i was like oh we really think
spice is very important obviously but
this woman straight up gave like a chunk
of concentrated spice versus spice that
has been cut with baking soda okay right
don't and you got to watch out for the
fentanyl that they cut spice with every
once in a while number one number two
someone said in the chat about the
trailer for fall in order too yes yeah
we just got that just dropped in the
last like hour or two okay um uh jedi
star wars survivor is what it's called
uh the trailer looks incredible that's
for the the video games of course um
yeah it looks great we we will probably
not cover it here on the channel but it
looks really cool we've got a couple of
big fans on the staff uh of that
franchise we can go back i just wanted
to make sure you guys are heard in the
chat yeah we saw that um
real quick we were talking before the
show about uncle owen this is the most
screen time just an episode one that
probably joel edgarten has had total in
the course in star wars did a great job
with it adding some personality a little
bit of depth to that character that we
haven't gotten to spend as much time um
also uh nexium cult survivor uh
joel edgerton no no no no no
um oh really that actress peru peru
didn't know yes
if you watched that series
that
documentary series um
um what was i going to say about his uh
about oh the line was in the trailer but
it hit so much harder watching the
series of when he's just like like you
saved anakin and i was like
he's right do you guys right uh it
struck me as like i'm not necessarily
confused but what do you think is going
on do you guys genuinely think obi-wan
was planning on training luke
yeah that that sequence was really
interesting to me and i think they're
gonna like flesh that out more because
he's like he's almost of age are you
gonna train him right and that spurred
that whole conversation that great line
and yet later
right with the call to action of like
hey kenobi come do this or when he
crosses past with that young jedi in the
desert both times he's like no no no i
don't do jedi stuff anymore i'm done
with that game someone in the chat might
be able to correct me here but wasn't he
specifically instructed by yoda to to do
this and to watch out for luke and train
well they said that in the flashback it
said that the beginning of the first
episode it was like
you know i i imagine it's like i will do
this one thing for yoda and i will not
do more but otherwise i'm hanging up the
cloak well i guess he also he didn't
necessarily have to train and again in
the chat correct me he didn't have to
train luke he just had to make sure he
was safe right
he says
you know uh
owen says you just want to know if he's
showing or whatever so there is an
implication there i get the implication
but i
i get the implication
i'm just saying also someone in the chat
said uh baby leia's acting was much
better than fleas
uh for about half the episode no the
entire first episode i thought he was
the actor who played needles and back to
the future oh yeah yeah yeah well really
yeah we might have
played i don't know
flea has a surprisingly deep filmography
i think being a rock star in los angeles
you just get cast in a lot of stuff i'm
raising my hand because i also want to
acknowledge one more thing that i did
not write in the script today
the fact that and i talked to john about
this earlier there's a part in the show
where they bring up the sewers and how
they're like all the worst people are in
the sewers and i'm like this is a
perfect time to bring up the darth maul
is in the sewers being reconstructed
into a spiderman but
speak of the devil
john's got to run to the sewers
this is right now this is not a real
tinfoil hat but this theory is very
whoa
i think well i'm gonna keep going no i'm
done but i don't he clearly isn't coming
out now especially now that we know like
the plot is about like him returning
baby leia and protecting the babies i'm
like oh we're
they said we're not seeing darth maul
i'm not seeing darth maul but it's like
i'm like how are we going to overlook
you never know two words
they could still really blow our minds
with the dartmouth
clown down there
mumba in the chat throwing out liam
neeson cameo as force ghost qui-gon we
talked about it
yesterday that was my prediction yeah
and i was like does that count with a
flashback because it counts he did sort
of andrew garfield himself and said he
only was going to come back to star wars
if it was a film now
and i say andrew garfield because like
he's got to be lying could have been
thrown us off the set yeah um also our
friend uh andrew mcmanaman
uh who who we quoted earlier we we made
a very similar joke earlier andrew i
love that flea was probably just in his
street clothes uh yeah you know um why
are we all coming for free like this
he loves playing he's pulled himself
back up from his bootstraps someone says
flea was absolutely needles in back to
the future and there you go
[Applause]
uh you know he was in uh big lebowski
the i believe the getaway the charlie
sheen vehicle i mean game of thrones
i know are you are you confusing him
coldplay yeah
he's in the wild thornberry uh the break
room all the greatest flea movie news
that came out three years ago it's
actually a good read i can't remember
the titles in my life
let's let's pitch the title for the flea
biography right now um
a flea on the wall
nice where's my shirt
yes i was gonna say flea circus
um yeah i'm somewhere in the in the red
hot chili powder
[Laughter]
oh well that was that spicy yeah he said
be gone
i could do 40 minutes on that drug
dealer she gave him enough drugs to
completely zonk
three full-sized adults out of their of
their gourd like that would have not
only gotten obi-wan hooked on spice that
would have gotten him hooked for like
uh
two years right first-time user that's
an overdose weight and a half yes you
lost the car yeah you lost the club
ma'am i don't think you understand how
economics works yeah okay i'm gonna get
you hooked on cocaine here's a kilogram
you guys noticed like just between uh
book of boba fett and this like suddenly
now there's like cool star wars teens
yes oh yeah dude in book of boba fett i
was like damn i want to get on that
little motorcycle to be those cool kids
i mean we all got uh bio bionic uh
uh body plants oh thunder installed i
now i now have a colon that can uh
handle anything wow
it's all those dark
speaking of which we want to thank our
friends
no transition hard stop
now we begin thanking our friends at
athletic greens for sponsoring uh
today's show um uh tommy was has been
messaging us that he's been drinking
athletic greens while down at star wars
celebration and we've got some here with
us ag-1 is the name of the athletic
greens product that i've got here in my
little canister and it's got 75 high
quality vitamins minerals probiotics and
all the other good stuff you need to
help you start your day and feel good
throughout the day again i take 40
almost 45 pills a day could just drink
it instead and you know what it tastes
good it's super portable in the little
thing here it comes in i've got both a
big old bag of ag-1 and also a little
box of uh single serving packets
the cool thing i was thinking about
heading into this weekend this is a
three-day weekend you know a lot of
folks might be going to barbecues doing
partying who knows traveling athletic
greens supports good rest and sleep so
maybe you don't have any plans for this
memorial day weekend
just sleep in well that's a good one i
love that i love that you know i forgot
to bring a lunch today and i was like
scrounging i was i was scrounging in the
back for like chips and all these little
things that i could keep myself full but
i was like okay i can't like
just have a lunch of potato chips and
weird rice crackers so i actually downed
one of these before the show and um i
feel lighter powerful i feel powerful i
will be murdering one of you at the end
of this wait if
if the super chats get redeemed what is
happening i sat here four tabletops and
we're only at 31
i'm filling in for tommy i have to be
more wow
yeah
whoa john phillip will fire me if i i
you are unfireable because you're on
athletic greens right now right also uh
we can't kill you with uh bacteria
because your immune system is boosted
that's right
that's right um and and we not only
prevented john from getting rickets with
athletic greens but we're all feeling
good on it uh and you know what right
now is a great time for you to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition just
through a scoop and a cup of water every
day it's really quick simple you don't
need uh unlike phillips um
massive elaborate uh supplement routine
you could just have this little guy uh
nobody's depository
you're the one with the mechanical colon
that's true that's true and it's never
felt better with athletic greens
[Applause]
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do hit the link
in this video's description that's
athleticgreens.com break room athletic
greens.com break room take ownership of
your health pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance thank you athletic
thank you athletic greens
fun thing to i realize about the super
chats is if it never breaks 100
jessica wore this wizard outfit
she
brought dice i mean guys okay is this
how normal tabletop usually go
one person cares way too much yeah
there's always one person and it's
usually me i dress up for it all the
time oh look what you're doing i like
dressing up i gotta say
you know what
we might need to
just do it right now you want to do it
now i think i think so now listen you
never give people for free what what
yeah we learned that from the spice
woman
yes
no maybe maybe that's what we need to do
we need to get the chat because i gotta
say we have at least five rounds of this
planned and filmed all right yeah there
you
go
okay then what we can give them for free
real quick is that we can quickly build
our characters yes you are well it
depends on which one uh if you guys are
how do we let's let's do you guys
let's do that you guys are fighter jet
pilots okay right fighter jet pilots
take you back into um top gunness it's a
great weekend for that so what what what
is your fighter names what are your
fighter names oh what's your call sign
ooh
curly q
curly cue
yeah known for my curls and my spirals
in the air oh
good one perfect well you john crash
test dummy ooh um i don't feel confident
flying airplanes it's a terrible name
for a guy
i feel i feel like i would be a terrible
pilot put me in the back seat with bob
how are you feeling the the helmet i
mean you that's gonna wrap around all
the way to the back crash test dummy
uh okay well it's easy to top that i'm
gonna say
uh i'm gonna be uh
they're gonna be corned beef
why is that better how is that better
how is that better everybody loves
corned beef i do
i don't like questions
one day a year we pretend not to hate it
the real the real reason he's called
corned beef we'll find out at some point
that's right it's a tragic backstory
quick we'll make this also i'm half elf
go for it okay perfect great so go ahead
and play me that quick clip
the number one threat to the box office
and that's marvel movies dr strange i'm
putting you on notice i'm here to take
you out and dominate the world totals
this weekend unless the break room can
stop me can you launch enough
surface-to-air missiles my ways to take
out this top gun
or will i drop a bomb all over you
eliminating you from the battlefield
entirely let's see what you got
it was so hard to get tom cruise wow man
his cameo is insanely expensive yes
that that that is the vector that we are
fighting again if you just joined us in
the last 30 minutes the news show
occasionally covers flea related yes and
the overall premise of this episode
inspired by the release of stranger
things anytime we hit a certain um level
in the super chat it'll activate us
fighting avecna in the form of a
tabletop game take it away thank you
zach okay maverick is coming to blow up
the studio and as our newest fighter
pilots curly q crash test dummy and
corned beef we gotta take him down first
so his bunker is in the mojave desert he
is sitting in his compound he's getting
prepared to kill us you guys are each in
your own f-14 jets what are you old ones
what are you doing okay all right well i
mean it's it's a kessel run-esque style
maneuver we have to get through right
we've got to avoid the surface-to-air
missiles the enemy pilots we got to
check radar gotta check right here go
ahead and roll for intelligence
roll first i'll decide if i am smart
enough to check right now
i've read everything about checking
right now
i need to check
you're definitely our leader you're our
top gun then for sure yeah uh may i
check right here check radar and you
find that he is indeed only 30 feet away
from you 30 feet away okay
you guys can circle back but he doesn't
hear you guys he doesn't hear you guys
because he's deep in the bunker i got to
get my targeting system online okay okay
targeting online
yes okay perfect go ahead
and put it offline you're rolling for
dexterity
that's gold a nine that's not bad
we're going to say that it can't link to
the spot right now the compound you have
to use manually oh manually fire okay
well then finally i'm um
i'm the wing man okay and i'm just gonna
roll for bombing this
okay me go ahead and hold this
bombing-ness yeah how bombing can i get
on on maverick let's do performance on
three okay you already shoot the bomb
you you click and shoot the bomb
prematurely it does not detach
that's attached yes it does not detach
everyone's like zac or corned beef
beef you know what that's this corned
beef
is toast is toast
what are you guys what are you talking
about we're still
let's do this for fun let's see if he
actually ejects himself
um
no spoilers for top gun africa because
most people haven't seen it coming out
today he's dying
i'm going to have a long spoiler-free
conversation with my friends about
talking no i'm kidding um okay he's
dying he's plummeting i gotta land my
jet you gotta hit the target john don't
save me
i'm
okay you're going for the target again
you're shooting manually you're gonna
shoot for dexterity and you have to get
above a 10. no okay here we go john
he shoots and he scores he hits the
target that's all right i didn't die in
vain john that's what's important the
target and now i do a curlicue in
celebration go ahead and show up for
performance yeah
i try to do the word cool
in cursive
saved something ah you hit me we're
going down i get eject oh goose i'm
coming for you baby
fourteen dollars away from getting
another one
good good good thank you uh and of
course um though that was tom cruise's
uh pete mitchell maverick from top gun
we also want to thank off-screen uh
brandon for contributing in some ways
and what way did he support that i just
morally yeah
someone uh definitely did a super chat
and donated to corned beef
that's a good name oh thank you out with
the daddy with the corn
the corn beef is much better i like that
nickname i like that everybody loves a
deli based nickname um are we ready do
you want to do some more super chats or
do you want to oh yeah real quick let's
um uh i'm paying 10 bucks to know where
jess got the the dress she's wearing can
i stand up because you are wearing that
girl it looks so comfortable and soft
and i want one that's from our great
friend chrissy throws in a couple emojis
there at the end um
uh oh yeah go back to this camera
look at that oh it looks even sorry
sorry it looks great in the background
too the little lights oh yeah that is a
great dress thank you um i got it it it
this is not like an actual dress it is a
dress but i got it from um
halloweentown hi no no where jack
skellington is the mayor
it's the store that's uh in la that's a
year-round halloween store called
halloween right down the street from us
here at new rock
magnolia boulevard but it's it's
actually one of my witch outfits that i
wear for tabletop and uh shouting out to
another one uh
shh
where did you go somebody just somebody
oh wait here we go andrew mcmackin yeah
again uh says are we sure 100 it's the
same grand inquisitor whoa
uh uh somebody else said oh we just
shane uh conlon is saying what if it's a
clone
yes i mean especially who did we see
that we saw some more american as a
cloned storm trooper then my favorite
part of the episode wasn't that great
and and possible uh fake beard there as
well so they're they're reminding us
like hey clowns exist i love that that
hadn't even crossed my mind we were like
oh well he can't be dead that's clearly
a character that exists in the canon and
we think he'll stick around but oh maybe
he is dead and that that was a clone
good point also yeah match 143
reiterating what we were saying earlier
baby leia is the epitome of perfect
casting that tiny actress did a great
job coming at us from canada thank you
tycho bro tycho bra 8 12 said what does
stinky obi-wan smell like
they made it really good
i feel like it's mildew because it's a
cave right yeah
have java's been known to be like
hypersensitive to smell he might he
might just have like a normal smell they
just hate it i'm gonna say he looks like
he smells great honestly like i don't
know why but something about you and and
you know he's like a dad okay yes i bet
yeah like uh um like he looks like he
like just came back from the beach and
he's got like a little salt but then
also just like sun and like just a bare
hint of some tanning lotion just working
in the sun cutting meat a little corned
beef
i'm smelling corn oh that that weird
sandwhale uh meat that was cutting out
yeah he was stealing that little quarter
piece each time yeah for his little
his little baby his little uh camel guy
kill him yeah irredeemable oh gosh i
should kill you uh but speaking of um of
moving on
and and in the obi-wan episode we got a
sneak sneak peek of eric voss's
breakdown of episode one that's coming
out on the channel tomorrow
um and we uh kind of combed through some
of the fun details that he was able to
spot we picked out a couple we like
john you've found a few things you play
they're really interesting
we don't want to give too much away i
think eric uh has a rental car and could
drive up from anaheim to l.a who gave
that man a rental car you gotta be 25.
that's right but some of the things that
we were talking about uh on our pre-show
call that we definitely do before this
show um
no none of us spotted we all saw the
c-3po cameo and another protocol droid
none of us spotted r2d2 did anyone see
rtd we have a photo
um that i hope is coming up there it is
look at that on the right there oh there
he is a very quick little
r2d2 cameo i think wow just talking to a
plant just getting on the planet
you know he's lonely um we we talked
brandon brought up the other day we were
talking about predictions and we're like
are we going to see 3po or r2d2 in the
series we got them both in the same
scene
do we know where the state of their
memory is
so what would it be uh r2d2 still has
his memory intact but c-3po was wiped is
that yes they're weight yes i think so
that sounds right yeah yeah i had uh a
long time ago a pitch for a tiger with
td spin-off star wars movie that was not
what they ended up doing but it was uh
him just doing a dedicated droid movie
with just r2d2 and c3po and it's just
about that's beautiful and i actually
like i like really plotted it out in my
head i don't know why where they exist
for like thousands of years and they're
like almost unstuck in time and they're
having a glitch and so we're
experiencing all of their adventures
a little bit
speaking of storytelling
so much um i think and speaking of uh
star wars i think we have a message from
an emperor i think i think
it is i your emperor
here to take over the break room with
the power of the dark side
why haven't i been in kenobi yet
it's already been two episodes and i
don't mean flashbacks
i want new scenes
new residuals
i will eliminate the break room with the
power of the duster
unless you and your pathetic jedi can
defeat me
put me in canali
thank you so much to carla ibarra for
pushing us over there
a lot of people don't know this the
break room set is on alderaan so we are
the lasers are
the stakes are high it's our mission to
stop him from getting on kenobi
i think that's exactly what i don't want
him to make
two dollars and 50 cents every six
months again uh thank you to ian
mcdarmod for sending that in to save
time i imagine we're roughly the same
characters
yes but you guys are now rebels ooh
disguise the storm troopers to try
getting in so we're now trying to make
sure he doesn't get into kenobi great i
would just like to say i'm the same
character but my name is now
corn gee
but i'm a huge jedi fan boy and so i
have a little braid that i turned into a
little acrylic
playing with it
uh i am crash test dummy in space
oh i like that one so you guys are now
storm troopers and we are troopers or
we're pretending to be you're you're
like rebels disguised as storm troopers
you got the suits you guys are in you
see uh emperor palpatine's uh captain
quarters he's behind these two doors but
there's two stormtrooper guards okay i'm
twisting my braid outside of the scene
between the neck and the helmet okay
what do we do guys okay um
who which of us can do the best voice to
impersonate a stormtrooper voice
uh
i see him
okay let's go ahead
so philip's gonna do the talking
okay
what am i gonna say oh um do we need to
roll for intelligence again like hey
come out here uh uh there's a uh
change oh you want a diverse role for
performance versus eve
okay oh if i if i'm even gonna vote okay
i studied at the uh acting school uh uh
on
jawa uh
academy
they teach beautiful dance um and i
approach and i'm getting my
throat warmed up they say what's your
status here
i say uh
here to report about the new jedi
nice
perfect what do you have to report
the
midichlorians are off the charts whoa
perfect believable someone should come
look at him quick all right perfect uh
who are these two
uh
homeboys
moral support hello
the emperor really needs to examine this
new jedi both of you roll for persuasion
okay wait what's your character i'm a
storm trooper okay all right 12.
they believe corned beef
they don't trust you
i am
palpable don't talk don't talk no no no
no
[Applause]
i am in a disguise as sort of an
undercover bus situation oh trying to
understand the light
of the storm quick reminder to my friend
here actual palpatine we know is in the
other room i'm just trying to get back
into my chamber
oh that works too go ahead and roll
for performance
okay
okay
i shoot this storm trooper in the head
yes yes go ahead go ahead and roll go
ahead and roll
this is for
12 12 12. you can survive
i'm gonna let you shoot him in the head
and they fall over oh and the other one
gets up he's like what's going on okay i
got his gun he's pointed right over okay
i've got to save i've got to save uh um
ctd over here uh 14. 14. you shoot him
in the chest shoot him in the chest okay
he falls over but the other one that i
shot on the head gets back up god wasn't
a strong enough hit i'm going to fake a
heart attack
go ahead and okay
i have a plan i'm faking a heart attack
i'm falling over
16. you fall over and have a heart
attack they step over you
okay
while they're stepping over me i would
like to grab their ankles and do some
sort of like crocodiles
if it's a turn-based system go ahead and
try to cross try to roll on that person
i rolled in a left hand you grab his
ankle and the other one steps on your
hand away you are now unconscious on the
ground okay go ahead there's two left
they have their two weapons pointed at
both of you we gotta stop
uh in space
okay there's still this guy here and
he's just stopping us i've got a space
grenade
uh
okay
we should probably try wait well that'll
kill us
[Music]
if it's going to kill the emperor yeah
let's do it yeah he's about to commit an
atrocity right okay uh this is a real
rogue one this is gonna be also rolled
for disc stairs
he throws it it doesn't detach it
so he throws that he lets it go it whips
it bounces off the wall and comes back
and it flows up
inject inject revenge
he gets blown up but this is also a
grenade so it does kill everybody but it
does not kill them it does
kill it it's a grenade it does not kill
emperor palpatine behind the guard oh no
palpatine wins we didn't defeat this
vecna i think we palpatine is going to
show up
pathetic
i know you could not defeat the dark
side and as punishment
each of you must do an impression of
your least favorite star wars character
do it
do it
someone in the chat said stop letting
zack handle explosives yeah
first bad idea
[Laughter]
so our least favorite oh your guys's
least favorite
i can barely do any impressions much
less of uh i'm just gonna do uh
yeah this is not a favorite character
but he has a distinctive voice i'm gonna
do least favorite i'm gonna do uh wado
from the frequent trilogy
hey
any
would you want to do that money
that's not your least favorite that's
pretty bad
um my least favorite star wars character
is finn in episode nine thank you and
i'm just gonna do right
nice that's pretty good when i when i
was like thinking about the punishment i
was like the only one i could say is
finn and doing that right impression so
i guess i'll mimic that and i can't do
impressions either
but essentially
yeah good mouth work
yes okay back to our break room
breakdown thank you for letting me roll
these dice and
put these boys to death yeah i think we
gotta lower this thing to every 20 bucks
i know some of these might have to roll
over to next week's uh table top a
couple quick uh super chats we want to
shout out uh timothy
uchaha i'm sorry if i'm mispronouncing
your name there if obi-wan doesn't say
hello there at least once this series is
not going to it'll be a failure you
think they won't no because this show is
like not without
as much as that
i want them to i think they'll do sort
of like uh
what was it at the end of
avengers age of ultron where they sort
of tease the avengers assembly and we
yeah yeah apparently like eu mcgregor
has been like pushing back on people
asking him to say it in interviews and
stuff like that like he's getting a
little tired of the meme we'll see we'll
see uh sean bell throwing out favorite
part darth tank assumed that shot at the
very end when he's in the back of the
tank you also called
back to tank too you were like oh yeah
we're gonna see ximena and then
yeah and like it does look awesome i
gotta say uh
darth tank is totally the kind of like
clever star wars character i would come
up with as a kid
well i'm dark tank
i also have treads in a can yeah yeah
yeah we did uh we threw some polls into
the chat which i think are interesting
who is your favorite uh new character
from this kenobi series 59 percent said
young leia which i agree with we didn't
talk about fake jedi kumail najini's
character on this show he barely talked
about third sister too yeah that's right
but i loved the idea that there's like a
con man running around like that yes i
love third sisters so much and since i'm
a villain lover that is true but oh my
god this person is a perfect villain so
it's hurts me that she's third
it's strange how low she is because
they're definitely they're setting that
character up to be a significant part of
the series and she was a badass in that
episode i mean very unlikable she's
clearly villainous but uh also likable
in the sense of like i want to watch
more of i can't wait for and i think she
has a better justification for being so
bad i want it to be better than like you
just want anakin to like you it's like
no i wanted to be like no obi-wan did
this to me and yeah you saved me maybe
she blames obi-wan for order sixties i
kind of i was thinking in it i was
thinking about that yeah oh yeah that'll
be a good reveal can we uh can we get
another detail from the the breakdown
yes so um one thing that that john
pulled out um it's kind of cool it's
it's uh oh there it is right when
obi-wan uh digs up his lightsaber which
kudos to him for remembering the exact
spot he buried it in that giant-ass
desert uh but when he pulls it out it's
real dusty in that shot and then later
when he's like when you kind of see it
on his hip right as he's boarding that
ship and when he's kind of holding it
later in the episode it's it's polished
and shiny and it's like yeah of course
this guy takes care of his weapon you
know much like we saw him wiping off the
the knife after working as the butchery
or whatever you know this is a guy who
respects his weapons yeah also a nice
touch of like even though he's maybe not
looking forward to what he's about to go
do he sort of feels regretful about
saying yes maybe he's still like i'm
going to do this the correct way yeah
there is a right way to do this and
there's like a deleted scene somewhere
that is like he disassembles it and like
like it uses little tools to like clean
it all out with the type of crystal but
yeah
of that yeah he's got a lot of tiny
little brushes and rags that he uses on
his would be really funny is if he
didn't do that it jams sometimes
we were debating this before the show
what episode do you think we see him
first use it three you think the very
next episode it felt like we should have
gotten it in this last episode
it's like clear that he won't since he
didn't use it against um
of moses uh angra moses uh the third
sister i think it has it's probably
gonna come out when he's fighting vader
i mean i think it's gonna be so long
he's not anti-violence he's down to use
a blaster on a big old crocodile headed
uh a bounty hunter or whatever
uh or or was it more of a raptor head
some kind of uh it's racist however you
tried it
hey big head gang right it was like a
little baby steps type situation where
he didn't want to use the force he he's
sworn off sort of what he's doing and he
only uses the force the last step when
pushing your legs
are people using their force sensitivity
at all because it feels like the
inquisitors could have known which uh
person patron in that bar was a jedi i
mean it could be how obi knows where the
lightsaber is right the crystal inside
might be pulling in but like it's
there's like an unknown amount of b yeah
cause because third sister's able to
just sort of read camille's mind right
to find out where obi-wan is right yeah
the amount of force usage i guess is
kind of like like maybe they're more
okay with using it and he's just barely
barely barely touched i think there's
also like techniques that they probably
are better at or not better at but like
ones that they've they're proficient in
that clearly obi-wan can do better than
everybody else because when i saw the
third sister i was like i feel like they
could have done a lot of things with the
force to find him by now like to do
anything but i think she only knew like
certain skills of the force does that
make sense do you see what i'm saying do
you have if you guys get what i'm saying
you know
yeah and you know the the force and all
the uses of the force has always been a
little vague as presented in in film and
maybe we'll get that defined a little
including the connection of a force user
and using a lightsaber
uh finn
some people use that as evidence that
his uh wielding the lightsaber was his
like force sensitivity showing
sensitivity
hey pull your pants up your sensitivity
is showing um and on that awful uh joke
uh probably a good time to wrap it up we
thank you to everybody we got a couple
rounds of the tabletop jessica put in a
lot of effort and uh thank you to our
special guest stars do you guys want to
do more oh i had a great time yes
i was terrible you mean right now what
do you mean in future episodes i think
as long as zack's not on your team
you guys will survive i'm not going to
be on the show often can we just do a
third one yeah
oh no let's do it
okay
wait wait oh my gosh
the vampire himself is here the vampire
himself is it morbid time
rudy giuliani
okay go ahead and play the clip
i am venom just kidding it's me dr
michael morbius at your service i'm here
for my twitch takeover where my film
morby has played for over 12 hours did
you know morbius currently has a rating
of over 278
on rotten tomatoes it's the best film of
the year and now i'm here to take over
your show the break room yes i'm gonna
turn this stream into a 58-hour morpheus
stream unless you can stop me from
drinking the red cause i've already had
the blue and now i gotta get that red
this chocolate fifty-eight more first
thing we need is this show going for 58
more hours that was a really fun time
you guys oh yeah it's a three-day
weekend it's three day weekend why not
going to try it oh my god daschle can't
we have to end the show we have to at
some point and i think the only way
we're gonna do it is we have to jump on
his cargo ship okay we have to jump on
the cargo ship that also has where his
experiments are where he's testing all
of his stuff let's keep in mind that
he's about to drink some red all we have
to do is get on the ship and the show
will end no you have to get on the ship
and defeat him
are you still corned beef
yes that'll be
mercenary corn beef yes yeah uh i will
be mercenary crash test dummy uh i will
be uh curly cube but it it applies to uh
uh deformity i was born with uh the
shape of my legs are twisted wow which
has never served me ever but
i am a very strong swimmer i was just
saying maybe yeah and have you also
really quickly and empathy play with
michael moore yes also have yes you know
i'm gonna have you i walked with the
same uh arm things for strength you got
an eight
um i didn't say i'm strong
you're swimming if you're swimming
you're pretty strong
how about i'm um real weak
but like i could float
yes a great floater you've never seen it
better you just have to hit above a 12.
honestly
he wrote an eight because i'm doing sort
of a mrs incredible thing where where
zack and i are just sitting on top of
philip while he
okay i get in the dinghy
you guys make it to the cargo ship okay
so we're on board
yeah i just real quick it's because in
the movie morbius it's so amazing how uh
they're swimming onto the ship oh that's
true not not here so you guys are on the
cargo ship it's a vast open cargo ship
there's no one there there's clearly no
one there's no guards there's nothing
there's one single door oh
i assume you guys are going to enter
uh hmm or is that what morbius wants us
to do whoa
while we are um
walking to the board this door i'm
slamming
bags of blue blood into baby bottles oh
yeah
so he's gonna force him he can settle on
him yeah yeah oh i'll allow it right
that's what we're supposed to do is stop
him from drinking our blood yeah
i i open the door you open the door
there's a long steep stair stair down
well stairwell stairwell you're going
into a basement
okay you guys are going into a basement
i want to search for the serum that
makes you into a vampire
in the basement yeah go ahead we're
going to do this for
this is going to turn out terrible for
us he's going to turn into a vampire and
he does oh dude remember when i said you
have to roll above a 12.
that's a three that's a three okay so
you take one step and you fall down the
stairs
you fall down the swimming was really
where i could have shot you fall down
the stairs making too much noise morbius
who's
who's there he comes looking for you
guys what is your guys's next step him
now searching for you
where's your grenade
i have a vampire bomb
no
it's got a thousand tiny little wooden
stakes
okay
but but i can pinpoint it right in front
of uh morbin so not only are you rolling
okay let's roll for dexterity let's see
if you can even aim that one i'm feeling
great about this 10.
right right in the middle i'm gonna give
you a good in the middle now let's see
are you gonna throw the bomb okay so i i
i rear back with my off hand and throw
the bomb
[Laughter]
you literally go i'm about to throw it
i'm about to throw it and you're like
lining it up but it's been pulled you've
been holding it for so long it just it
explodes
it's gone it is left to the two of you
he's at the bottom of the stairs you're
still oh stairs oh duh i'm alive wait
yourself i just got a bunch of little
pigs in my face i fell so bad i examined
my legs they looked better than they've
ever learned before
wow that's secure uh i'm gonna run down
the stairs it's morbid time okay i'm
gonna have him roll for his legs
you two are ready you run down the
stairs morpheus morpheus morpheus is
there he's ready to attack
and you guys i'm chucking that baby
bottle right and do his gullet oh smart
here we go
we're going to plug the hole
fine
it just hits him in the head it falls to
the ground now he zips over okay and
this is when i roll oh no i know oh no
he zips over and he slashes
crash test dummy's neck he starts
sucking it he's so strong i rolled a d12
and got a 12 baby but he's he's supposed
to be a good guy
last that is left the last hero we have
he's looking you in the eyes what is
your call i go for a kiss oh yes oh
we're gonna do this for charisma
a 15 and kiss him on the lips the blood
drips down your cheek he goes
okay
he's interested
he likes what you're putting down
he goes i need to finish this really
quick i have to uh assault an entire uh
live stream that's going to go for 58
hours but do you want to join me
of course i want to join you i want to
join you forever for all of eternity
okay
[Applause]
the live stream goes on for 58 hours
with
with curling cues just joining the bad
side wait i didn't realize that that was
gonna end it yeah that's how it ends and
now we get to see what morbius did as he
defeated us
why would you enjoy it
i told you you can beat dr michael
morbius now i'm the winner and as your
punishment all of you have to finish
your drink now like you were drinking
the red
more
hey
cheers
what a way to go wow to me and michael
morbius oh happy evening
happily ever after thank you all so much
for joining us on this uh weird and wild
friday episode we'll be back next
tuesday we're taking memorial day off as
you should as well the latest flea news
that's right cutting edge red hot chili
peppers basis news uh but we'll be
talking more oh we're getting another
obi-wan episode tuesday at midnight into
wednesday we also have uh next week next
friday the boys the boys debuts season
three we have enough time to watch
anything about stranger things yes
we'll have a breakdown of that coming
out next week
this is horrible do not drink bubbly it
makes you burp you have to drink this um
we will touch on it maybe next week
there and everybody should watch it's
very fun the moon night behind the
scenes there's a new moon night behind
the scenes where they're talking about
like everything that was for moonlight
and everyone should watch it because
it's just another flash flash from the
past also everyone should see moon fall
because that is a crazy movie
um
keep saying bye keep saying bye i'm
gonna keep rolling this dice until i get
a d
six
[Music]
[Music]
streaming
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you